i
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález costa rica
la democracia más estable de
centroamérica vivió una jornada
electoral en total calma en donde la
gran protagonista fue la abstención que
alcanzó el 42 85% el triunfador de los
comicios fue rodrigo chávez quien se
convertirá entonces en el presidente
número 49 de costa rica tras haber
liderado una campaña política que centró
su mensaje en el cambio y también en la
lucha contra la corrupción el nuevo
presidente electo es el del naciente
partido progreso nacional democrático de
centroderecha d obtuvo el 52 9% de los
votos lo que le permitirá asumir la
presidencia el próximo 8 de mayo para un
período de 4 años si participaron en
estas elecciones como ya lo decíamos una
extensa carrera ha tenido este
presidente a lo largo oeste candidato a
lo largo de los últimos meses el
participó en estos comicios a través de
un partido nuevo pero venía de tener una
carrera internacional en organismos
internacionales en donde sus luces y sus
sombras los detalles en el siguiente
informe que fue preparado por la
redacción de france 24
economista de profesión y natural del
distrito del carmen en costa rica
rodrigo chávez obtuvo un doctorado
económico en la universidad de ohio lo
que le abrió las puertas al banco
mundial donde trabajó durante más de 25
años
en 2019 el político renunció a su cargo
y volvió a costa rica comenzó su carrera
política al ser fichado para ocupar el
ministerio de hacienda puesto que
desempeñó durante 184 días y del que
también terminó renunciando no fue hasta
2021 cuando anunció que se unía al
partido social democrático desde donde
ha defendido políticas conservadoras con
un discurso nacionalista a favor de la
recuperación económica del país a través
de pactos con organismos como el fm el
actual acuerdo negociado pueden
mejorarse de acuerdo a los intereses del
país y que yo estoy muy anuente
renegociarlo con el compromiso de que no
incluirá más impuestos en su corta
trayectoria política chávez ya se ha
visto envuelto en varias polémicas el
mismo año que abandonó el banco mundial
este lo sancionó por acoso sexual a dos
de sus trabajadoras entre 2008 y 2013 y
recientemente el periódico wall street
journal publicó que chávez también
habría acosado a mujeres en indonesia
entre 2 1000 18 y 2019 acusaciones que
siempre ha negado el periodista quien
tardó dos semanas para escribir la nota
afirma que hubo una conducta inapropiada
necesidad de indolencia y saber cómo
sustenta esa temeraria afirmación
como gente familiarizada con el caso el
político muy popular entre los
costarricenses también ha sido señalado
por financiar su campaña con cuentas
bancarias no declaradas
pues estas denuncias y sanciones por
acoso sexual por parte de varias de sus
compañeras de trabajo durante su paso
cuando era funcionario del banco mundial
ha sido la mancha en su carrera y tal
vez el escándalo más sonado sin embargo
esto no le impidió convencer a muchos
costarricenses que apostaron por un
político y un partido que no hace parte
de la tradición política tica chávez
recibe una costa rica con una economía
seriamente afectada que intenta
recuperarse de la pandemia de kobe 19 y
que busca ser mucho más atractiva para
los inversionistas y para el turismo sin
embargo para los ciudadanos hay otras
prioridades según esta encuesta de la
universidad de costa rica el 29,1 por
ciento de los encuestados indicaron que
lo que más les preocupa es el desempleo
para el 17,8 de los costarricenses el
tema primordial es la economía del país
y para el 10 6% el tema de preocupación
es la corrupción
pero el presidente electro rodrigo
chávez se tiene otros retos también por
delante gobernar con una bancada de
apenas 10 diputados en un total de 57
que conforman el legislativo por ende
deberá tejer alianzas y también
incrementar el dinero de las arcas
públicas y hacer frente a la llegada de
emigrantes procedentes de nicaragua
también como el narcotráfico y también
potenciar el sistema de bienestar y
apostarle por el desarrollo de las
regiones sobre todo de las costas de
costa rica- que son las regiones menos
desarrolladas si se comparan con el gran
valle central entre otros temas pues que
vamos a analizar en esta edición del
debate hoy en nuestro programa quién es
rodrigo chávez y qué retos tendrá como
presidente de costa rica para analizar
este tema hemos invitado a eugenia
aguirre ella es politólogo también
investigadora de la apn a usted está en
la ciudad de san josé la capital de
costa rica- también está con nosotros
maría fernanda bustamante ya también es
politóloga del observatorio de política
nacional también de costa rica y también
se encuentra en la ciudad de san josé
ustedes nuestros televidentes
pueden participar en este debate con sus
comentarios y sus preguntas lo pueden
hacer a través de nuestras redes
sociales no se encuentran en facebook en
instagram y en twitter estamos como
france24 bajo ese santi logo que es mi
cuenta personal y les recuerdo la
etiqueta es numeral el debate efe 24
esperamos sus comentarios y sus
preguntas comienzo entonces con eugenia
en la ciudad de san josé como punto de
partida este debate el balance que hace
de esta jornada electoral nuevamente un
país democrático fue a las urnas pero en
este caso con una alta abstención como
lo decía yo eugenia tal vez la
protagonista de la jornada cuáles son
sus impresiones
muchas gracias santiago por la
invitación al debate 1 no me gustó
compartir de nuevo en la jornada
electoral transcurrió con tranquilidad
sin ningún tipo de incidente sus siempre
un orgullo para el este país y por
supuesto también un reconocimiento del
trabajo del organismo electoral
fue también una jornada caracterizada
por la baja participación de la
ciudadanía en indicadores históricos
tanto en primera vuelta como en segunda
vuelta
y ese abstencionismo al menos por los
estudios que hemos realizado que datan
de antes de la fecha de la segunda
vuelta indicaban que un 42 por ciento de
las personas que manifestaron que no
iban a acudir a las urnas era porque
sentían rechazo o disgusto hacia alguna
de las dos candidaturas no hay que
olvidar que que estos dos candidatos que
se encontraban en segunda vuelta fueron
electos por tan sólo el 26 por ciento
del padrón electoral y se percibió ese
ausentismo en las urnas como nunca antes
maría fernanda su opinión el balance que
usted hace de esta forma de electoral
allí en su país en costa rica
sin duda alguna es sin duda alguna y
retomando las palabras de mi compañero
eugenio podemos ver que la política
tradicional y las figuras tradicionales
la figura sobre todo del candidato
verdiblanco josé maría figueres hijo del
caudillo que necesitaría política de
costa rica- muy importante un partido
del que tiene más de 70 años en el
ejercicio del poder llega nuevamente por
tercera vez a una segunda ronda y no
puede conseguir la silla presidencial
esto significa que el desgaste
consecutivo de la política tradicional
las figuras tradicionales y quizás esta
apelación a sentimientos
ideológicos no ha sido suficiente para
hacer una estrategia que logre en
aumentar la simpatía de la ciudadanía
costarricense con esta propuesta
política además vemos que en contraste
el candidato ahora o presidente rodrigo
chávez viene con un partido que se forma
en 2018 y que logra llamar la atención
que crece en la intención de voto a
partir de octubre del año pasado y
finalmente se mantiene liderando las
encuestas de intención de voto durante
todo el mes de marzo hasta que gana las
elecciones la noche de allí bueno está
claro el panorama y ya ustedes han
tocado varios de los temas que tenemos
en la agenda para analizar en el
programa maría fernanda continuó con
usted allí en san jose que dice para la
política costarricense que el presidente
electo sea rodrigo chávez ustedes hablan
de este partido de nuevo que no es una
figura que pertenece a la clase
tradicional de la política costarricense
que dice exactamente para la política
del país que el presidente sea chávez
bueno hay varias líneas porque el
proceso ha sido bastante complejo como
lo es en general la política nacional de
cualquier país en primer lugar tenemos
que rodrigo chávez viene a formar como
un outsider verdad una persona que
quizás no ha estado no se le conoce
fácilmente como el contrincante que
teníamos en esta segunda vuelta y sin
embargo a pesar de que sea una figura
que no ha tenido la misma experiencia
que otros partidos políticos o que las
figuras tradicionales en el país ha
logrado calar en la intención de voto de
la ciudadanía y es interesante también
observar que a pesar de que sea una
figura en este en estos términos
relativamente nueva no necesariamente su
partido o la ideología de la que
representa se diferencia
significativamente de las otras ofertas
políticas que estaban disputando esta
ronda presidencial incluso en la
asamblea legislativa que ya se conoce la
conformación son 57 personas electas
así definidas el
6 de febrero pasado vemos que se estima
que aproximadamente hay un 10% de
ideología política más direccionada
hacia la izquierda y el resto está
direccionada hacia la derecha en este
sentido el candidato rodrigo chávez si
se presenta de nuevo como una figura
relativamente nueva en la política en el
escenario político costarricense sin
embargo
no necesariamente está tan tan
desalineado de lo que estamos
entendiendo sobre la conciencia con esta
presencia eugenia y su opinión sobre
este tema que rodrigo chávez sea el
presidente que tanto es en línea con lo
que dice maría fernanda que caló su
discurso entre los costarricenses o
simplemente un poco de hartazgo o un
poco de descarte
bueno creo que es un poco de todo como
manifestado hasta ahora descarte
hartazgo o rechazo lo tradicional pero
en resumiría el sentir con el hecho de
que rodrigo chávez hoy sea presidente
electo de nuestro país refleja una
intención de cambio de un porcentaje muy
importante de la población respecto a la
clase política y respecto a los partidos
políticos ya conocidos es un mensaje de
cambio que es reciclado por decirlo de
alguna manera de las campañas
electorales sobre todo 2014 cuando llega
por primera vez un partido distinto al
bipartidismo al poder ejecutivo el llamo
el cambio verdadero y creo que ahí se
sustenta toda su narrativa y
anti-corrupción también y muy en el
fondo también anti política se trata
también de un mensaje muy claro hacia el
mundo entero con toda la pena que esto
pueda significar el respecto a la
valoración nacional sobre los derechos
de las mujeres a vivir en entornos y
trabajar en entornos libres de violencia
y más que hablar respecto a también un
mensaje muy claro que da la ciudadanía
respecto a concederle el poder desde el
ejecutivo creer o no garantizarle una
mayoría en el legislativo es decir una
población que apuesta por este cambio
pero en él por el lado de su contrapeso
constitucional que significa las curules
o los escaños en la asamblea legislativa
no se le otorga esa vía libre sino una
vía que le obligará a negociar y
establecer acuerdos eugenia en ese orden
de ideas entonces quien es de la
sociedad de la población costarricense
respaldaron este cambio quienes
respaldan esta ciudad de este partido y
esta propuesta que hace el presidente
electo rodrigo chávez quienes son estos
votantes
en el apoyo a rodrigo saucedo roble y
vino de parte de sobre todo de
provincias costeras y territorios
rurales y fronterizos esto también
implica un mensaje
y exclusión de las políticas de
desarrollo nacional fuera del gran área
metropolitana recordemos que costa rica
haya sido catalogada en muchas ocasiones
como una economía de dos niveles una
nueva economía anclada al mundo y la
otra una economía que sufrió muchísimo a
partir de la pandemia y es este este
sector de la población que ha expresado
en zonas geográficas nos lleva a lo
costero lo fronterizo y lo rural el que
elige masivamente a rodrigo chávez lo
que es el área el gran área
metropolitana opta mayoritariamente por
la opción de josé maría figueres de la
provincia de cartago y en la provincia
de san josé al igual igualmente sabíamos
ya por estudios de opinión que rodrigo
chávez ser apoyado mayoritariamente por
hombres de mediana edad
i
buscaban en la figura de este candidato
ese recambio y también pues parte de un
modelo a seguir
y se trata también de una una población
que en muchas circunstancias ha votado
de manera distinta de hecho santiago si
revisamos la historia de las elecciones
de 2014 2018 es la primera vez que el
candidato de las zonas fuera del gran
área metropolitana queda electo a la
presidencia ha sido tradicional que hay
una fractura claro entre como vota lo
rural y lo urbano como es una tendencia
por supuesto en toda américa latina y
eso es muy diciente de cara a próximos
comicios sin duda alguna entonces los
candidatos van a estar prestando un poco
más atención a esos votantes de las
zonas costeras de las zonas menos
desarrolladas y no tendrán el foco en el
valle central o en las provincias
cantones del centro del país en varias
fernanda hablábamos en el reportaje
previo en el que poníamos en contexto a
los televidentes sobre estas acusaciones
de acoso sexual cuando chávez trabajaba
en él
en una organización internacional hubo
señalamientos por varias de sus
compañeras sin embargo este tipo de
acosos pese a que salió en toda la
prensa tanto costarricense como prensa
internacional parece que los votantes no
les importó y se quedaron con el perfil
económico que tiene chávez y que tal vez
pueda darle un impulso a la economía
costarricense tal vez sólo a lo que le
están apostando estos estos votantes
cuál es su análisis al respecto cómo
logra el presidente electo capotear
digámoslo así estas acusaciones y este
caso que bueno pasó ya hace algunos años
atrás
claro sin duda alguna debemos referirnos
a la triste realidad y es que las
dinámicas patriarcales actitudes
misóginas y la desigualdad estructural
que vivimos en el país en las
instituciones políticas y en toda
américa latina seguramente en todo el
mundo también es se apunta a que hay
pocos mecanismos de
de contención o de control político o
que más bien es la representación la que
no se ha distribuido en términos
equitativos
o igualdad de género a lo que voy con
este punto es que el estudio de opinión
que tuvimos en costa rica a inicios del
mes de marzo apuntaban hicieron una
pregunta específica sobre cuál era la
veracidad que consideraba la población
encuestada sobre las acusaciones de
corrupción en el caso de josé maría
figueres y en el caso de ahora
presidente rodrigo chávez sobre el acoso
sexual la población encuestada manifestó
que estas que éstas que estos
cuestionamientos eran verídicos
sin embargo afectaban en mayor medida al
candidato verdiblanco josé maría
figueres y en menor medida al aura
electo el candidato a la presidencia de
euro de luchas que hoy es presidente del
grupo para a partir de los chamanes
presidente de la república y
presidente electo si está esta
configuración también se mezcla con el
hecho de que el país ha pasado por una
situación fiscal muy crítica ha tenido
dos ciclos de procesos activos del oro
largos en la historia del país desde el
2018 2019 a la fecha una ley anti
huelgas en el país muy importante en
esta
legislatura que va saliendo y en este
sentido
logramos equiparar que esta situación
fiscal en conjunto con las consecuencias
que ha tenido la pandemia de ccoo y 19
han apelado han reforzado el ideal de
que rodrigo chávez con su carencia de
economista puede generar un cambio en el
país para fernanda por favor un poco más
junto a las respuestas que se nos va el
tiempo y tengo muchos temas para hablar
con ustedes sigo con usted allí en la
capital de costa rica para preguntarles
la conformación del legislativo el
presidente electo solamente tiene 10
curules en la asamblea legislativa va a
tener que hacer negociaciones o
coaliciones o alianzas con los 5
partidos que están allí representados en
el congreso justamente el pl n que es el
partido de figueres
tiene más legisladores tiene 19 en total
como podría conformarse el legislativo
maría fernanda desde su opinión con
quienes podría aliarse y qué tanta carga
podría llegar a tener hablo para tratar
de llegar a esa mayoría que sería lo que
le permitiría gobernar con un poco más
de tranquilidad muy puntual por favor
el gabinete de don rodrigo chávez debe
asumir una oposición que es la
minoría más grande y en este momento que
es de liberación nacional que tiene 19
curules y el partido oficialista solo
tiene 11 en este sentido se necesitan
para generar acuerdos mayoría simple de
26 candidatos o para cierto tipo de
leyes de mayor mayor asociación de
diputados en este sentido debe ser muy
cuidadoso el poder ejecutivo a la hora
de presentar la agenda a la hora de
generar acuerdos ya que también tuvimos
omisión de adhesiones y de coaliciones
en estas preguntas en esta segunda ronda
electoral en este sentido los otros
bloques de diputaciones no no han
expresado su deseo de colaborar de
buenas a primeras en algún tema
específico
también tenemos que el ejecutivo va a
iniciar su periodo constitucional con el
dominio de la agenda legislativa vamos a
tener entonces brevemente
en estos primeros meses en estos
primeros 100 días de gobierno cómo va y
sobre qué temas más importantes es los
que considerando rodrigo
y cambios en el buen y su opinión en
cuanto a legislativo las negociaciones
con las otras cinco fuerzas que están
allí como es su panorama complejo
santiago es un congreso que va a tener
que tomar acuerdos coyunturales según
temáticas de interés tenemos por primera
vez los extremos ideológicos dentro del
congreso la izquierda con una fuerza
importante así como la derecha más hacia
el extremo y en consecuencia el panorama
del poder ejecutivo para plantear
negociaciones con el legislativo deberá
ser pensado en términos de temáticas en
donde se encuentren coincidencias en
este sentido será central como planteaba
maría fernanda la relevancia que le vaya
a dar rodrigo chávez a los primeros tres
meses de su gestión que por primera vez
en la historia serán dirigidos por él en
el congreso y la construcción de
mayorías era como en este periodo
constitucional que está por concluir un
ejercicio cotidiano y relacionado
directamente con intereses temáticos
donde puedan haber coincidencias ya
costa rica- pasado por estos entornos
multipartidistas y hay algunas
experiencias positivas que pueden servir
para que el presidente chávez plantee
estrategias pero alianzas irrestrictas o
alianzas sólidas y permanentes se ve
difícil también por lo confrontativa que
fue la campaña electoral claro pasamos
ya un poco más allá de la mitad del
programa pasamos a los retos retos muy
importantes en tiene el presidente
electo rodrigo chávez para costa rica
tema principal que tal vez es como el
que más llama la atención es la
recuperación económica de este país que
tiene que hacer grandes esfuerzos para
sostener su estado bienestar que he
hecho fue un gran ejemplo en su momento
para la región de américa latina eugenia
retos del país cuáles deben ser los
puntos de ataque digamos en estos 100
primeros días y en esta y en este inicio
de gobierno
bueno prometió el presidente chávez a
los primeros 100 días atacar
directamente el alto costo de la vida
relacionado con el precio de los
agroquímicos el precio del arroz el
precio de los medicamentos y otros
insumos que él aduce
se mantenían a precios muy altos para la
adquisición de productos de la
ciudadanía de razón de monopolios
de sus adversas adversarios políticos
que sacaban provecho económico entonces
hay un gran peso sobre esta promesa que
manifestó a lo largo de la campaña y que
también indicó era algo que se podía
resolver desde un decreto ejecutivo otro
gran reto que tiene de cara a los
organismos internacionales es un proceso
que quiere iniciar sobre renegociar las
metas con el fondo monetario
internacional para los desembolsos de
recursos que hoy por hoy tienen
pendiente la aprobación de dos
legislaciones sobre renta global dual e
impuestos a las viviendas de lujo él ha
manifestado que por el lado del gasto y
el combate la evasión se podría no
alcanzar las metas propuestas sin
necesidad de reformar la carga
tributaria si el tercer reto no santiago
y no lo puedo dejar de mencionar es
tender puentes con sectores sociales y
con las demás agrupaciones políticas
venimos de una campaña muy agresiva
de la que él fue uno de los principales
voceros y de la que tendrá que
disociar se tendrá que empezar a manejar
un discurso mucho más conciliador y de
diálogo para alcanzar las metas que se
propuso en su primer discurso habló
precisamente de eso de unidad llamó al
ex presidente figueres a unir fuerzas y
también a las otros a las otras fuerzas
políticas a unificar esfuerzos para
poder
llegar a puerto juntos y finalmente si
le va bien a el país le va bien a todos
en maría fernanda su opinión en cuanto a
los retos ya hablamos de la parte
económica pero también hay unos retos
grandes en educación el desarrollo de
las áreas costeras y rurales y también
en la corrupción y pues fomentar la
inversión extranjera que es sumamente
importante para costa rica
claro el
presidente electo rodrigo chávez ha sido
muy vehemente en su posicionamiento
anticorrupción sobre todo porque al ser
un partido nuevo está desligado de estos
casos de corrupción tradicionales que
han surgido a partir en toda la historia
costarricense pero han surgido con mayor
en
importancia en el 2021 2018 y por ahí
además de esto ha permitido que el
ministerio de educación pública sea
intervenido y sea sustituido se como
nuevas líneas de acción ya que este es
un sector que desde antes de la pandemia
sobre todo la educación secundaria ha
tenido muchos retos específicos que no
se han logrado solventar con la crisis
de el cubil 19 estas desigualdades se
han disparado y ahí es donde entran las
propuestas del presidente electo don
rodrigo chávez para modificar
e intervenir sobre todo utilizando esta
palabra administrar la educación pública
maría fernanda él le será fácil al
gobierno poder gobernar valga la
redundancia teniendo como punto de
partida
una fuerza política un partido nuevo que
no tiene mucha estructura que no tiene
unas caras visibles reconocidas que
prácticamente se tendrá que amar a armar
sobre la marcha del inicio desde el
inicio del gobierno como lo ve usted
sin duda alguna gobernar es complejo en
el escenario que tenemos actualmente
la posición confrontativa de la que
hemos mencionado en este programa ha
sido y será una de las principales
actitudes a modificar en esta en este
intento de crear puentes no sólo con el
poder con el poder legislativo sino
también con los sectores sociales como
mencionaba eugenia hemos también
identificado que hay ciertos sectores de
la sociedad que están esperando un
cambio y en ese sentido estas
expectativas que fueron las que
finalmente se representaron en las urnas
el día de ayer deben ser afrontadas de
la mejor manera para mantener la
legitimidad con la que llegó don rodrigo
chávez al poder que es diferente a la
representación que pueda llegar a tener
oa mantener durante los próximos en los
próximos años si entiendo eugenia su
opinión sobre esta estructura de partido
y cómo puede ser gobernar con un partido
nuevo que está prácticamente naciendo y
que no tiene experiencia además
en la primera vez en la historia de
costa rica- santiago que nos enfrentamos
a una situación de estas de contar con
un partido nuevo que va asumir el poder
el presidente chávez deberá llenar
alrededor de 900 puestos en toda la
administración pública para efectos de
iniciar su gestión de gobierno y ya ha
anunciado que al menos para la
conformación del gabinete generará un
equipo que le ayude por mejores perfiles
elegir a las mejores personas para el
puesto esto pone un riesgo sustantivo
respecto a la formación de cuadros ya
que se ha orientado hacia una lógica a
privilegiar una lógica de la
meritocracia de la tecnocracia y en
consecuencia
no no no queda claro qué tipo de
capacidades políticas estará buscando en
su equipo de trabajo y ya manifestó
donde cambio el discurso además de su
campaña electoral e indicó el día de hoy
a la ciudadanía en conferencia de prensa
que podrá o que buscará también echar
mano de cuadros de otras agrupaciones
políticas puesto que anterior y además
anteriormente lo había negado realmente
el reto a pocas semanas de asumir un mes
y unos días flip para el presidente
chávez y su gabinete es esencial ya
tiene conformado un equipo de transición
para los efectos eugenia hablemos de las
lecciones que dejan estos comicios en
costa rica unas elecciones que
contrarias a las elecciones pasadas no
tuvieron un tema transversal como era el
del matrimonio igualitario estas
elecciones no tuvieron un tema de
controversia transversal el reyno la
abstención muy alto para un país como
costa rica una democracia consolidada en
la región de centroamérica y también una
serie apatía por parte de los ciudadanos
que elecciones deja este país
centroamericano para otros países que se
van a enfrentar a comicios como por
ejemplo colombia o brasil qué son los
próximos a lo largo de este año
las lecciones giran muy en torno a
posibles reformas electorales tenemos
que valorar a la luz de este resultado
no solo la manifestación de la
ciudadanía que expone la necesidad de
cambios y derry y de asumir retos
históricamente relegados sino la
necesidad de valorar reformas respecto
al tema de financiamiento de los
partidos políticos respecto a la fórmula
a partir de la cual se eligen las
diputaciones y otros de índole
estructural por otra parte una gran
lección para las agrupaciones político
partidarias más tradicionales respecto a
si tienen una posibilidad de enganchar
con un electorado cuyas dinámicas o
cuyas demandas son más complejas que
hace 70 años y por supuesto es un
mensaje o un aprendizaje respecto a la
personalización de la política y hoy por
hoy el bajo valor que ha adquirido las
agrupaciones son las estructuras para
ordinarias frente a liderazgos
altisonantes y maría fernanda a su
opinión sobre estas lecciones que dejan
los comicios en costa rica para la
región para centroamérica y bueno para
también para américa latina
complementando es importante resaltar el
papel de las redes sociales y las
plataformas digitales también la nueva
configuración a la que se están
acercando los medios de comunicación y
nuevas dinámicas en el electorado son
representadas a través de nuevas
dinámicas de poder en la forma de
comunicar estos mensajes y por donde
están llegando
estos mensajes políticos esta persona es
personalización de la política que
comentaba eugenia también se ve
contrastada con la
ausencia de simpatizantes a bases
electorales es decir la ciudadanía se ve
menos interesada en participar en
utilizar distintivos de los partidos
políticos porque no se sienten
identificados o no sienten la suficiente
atracción política para realizar este
tipo de activismo no entonces estas
dinámicas también erosiona otras partes
de la estructura como lo podrían ser los
controles políticos que se tienen a la
hora de ejercer el voto sea hora de
representación en puestos que no sean
solamente del gobierno central me quedan
ya pocos minutos para finalizar el
programa y quiero citar algunas de las
sugerencias que hizo la misión electoral
de la oea allí en costa rica después de
estos comicios y hablan de un punto
importante y es la participación de la
mujer en estos comicios y en esta
carrera presidencial en general
aprovechando que tenemos panel de
mujeres invitadas de primerísimo nivel
quiero conocer su opinión maría fernanda
comienzo por usted sobre la escasa
participación de las mujeres en estos
comicios si bien costa rica ya tuvo una
presidenta en estos comicios no hubo
candidatas
en estos comicios tuvieron
ciertas candidatas que disfrutaron la
silla presidencial en la primera ronda
sin embargo siguen siendo minoría esto
responde a cuáles son las estructuras
que llevan a las mujeres a querer
participar ya que los retos de las
mujeres para participar activamente en
política son distintos a los de nuestros
padres no tenemos que hablar solamente
de cómo generar los mecanismos
necesarios para que las mujeres puedan
ocupar un puesto de representación
política sino también de cuáles son
aquellos retos aledaños que impiden la
participación de las mujeres en política
sentir lo asociado a muchos otros
factores que son igual de complejos
eugenia rápidamente porque me queda ya
un minuto para finalizar el programa su
opinión bueno haciendo un balance hay
importantes resultados en términos de la
conformación del congreso por primera
vez tendremos bueno tendremos el
congreso más paritario en nuestra
historia con 27 mujeres diputadas eso
quiere decir que lo que tiene que ver
con cargos a órganos colegiados y listas
de votación que presentan los partidos
políticos al electorado mujeres a partir
de las reglas por supuesto electorales y
les va mejor y ahora tenemos un reto y
lo mantenemos también en el gobierno
subnacional en los gobiernos
subnacionales que se relaciona con los
cargos uninominales alcaldías alcaldesas
presidentas en esta ocasión quien estuvo
cerca fue la candidata línea de saborío
sin embargo a lo largo del mes de enero
fue perdiendo apoyo y habla también pues
de los retos palabras desde las mujeres
en política eugenia maría fernanda
muchas gracias por haber hecho este
análisis de estos comicios
presidenciales allí en costa rica muchas
gracias por haber estado con nosotros y
a ustedes muchas gracias por la sintonía
y pueden seguir con la programación de
france 24 y también pueden ver más
información en france 24 punto com
[Música]